i mean i i just don't see the content  chance  after h5  do i have a better square for my queen  could go  there are no good squares actually  i mean standing in the diagonal yeah you  don't want to enter into the pin right  e6 this comes with tempo  he's in trouble he's in real big trouble  yeah because the g4 square is an  incredibly important square for the  bishop so nice  keep black tied  on d1 it was just a very passive piece  practically doing nothing  and after having it on g4  it's a whole different story yeah white  has all the resources like b4 is there  h5 really helps as well taking the g6  square and stabilizing the bishop can  never get hit know about that  he's not going to be playing in the  olympia  the us still have a pretty good team  there  became so strong in the last few years  apart from having their